Speaker 1: I have a voicemail number
that you can call any time you want.
This is an anti-vaccine caller who's been calling
in for a while. She took up a full three minutes
today on the voicemail. That's the max. It cuts
you off. Let's listen to a little bit of it.
It's some pretty, pretty full on stuff.
Speaker 5: Yeah. Remember, when you get
to go to some clinic somewhere and get
your vaccine ahead of the crowd there?
Speaker 1: Yeah, that didn't happen.
Speaker 5: Wow! Talk about being a dickhead.
Listen. Guess what, this wears off. You got to
go get another one, like, that's not a setup.
Billions are being made, and that's why they're
turning away any other possible solutions.
Speaker 1: There's like that's there's no
evidence of that. I mean, billions are being made,
but there's no evidence of the second part.
Speaker 5: So you got a bad cold,
right, but you got,
Speaker 1: by the way, it sounds like Roseanne
Barr, but I know Roseanne's politics aren't like
Speaker 5: this. You prefer you got cough sirup.
You got your basic drugstore, right? Yeah, you
don't have to go to the emergency for that,
but they've taken away something that someone
could take if before they got in a position
where they needed to go to the emergency
room. And yes, steroids are a really bad
drug unless they're helping you not die.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So steroids haven't been
taken away. I mean, if it's pretty typical
that for certain COVID, you give dexamethasone
or maybe they're using prednisone and we know
about the effect of steroids, I mean, it does.
It does suppress the immune system to a degree,
but maybe allows healing to take place. There's
nothing new is nothing controversial there
Speaker 5: there helping it not die.
God damn how much you much is
Pfizer paying you for this boy?
Speaker 1: You know, what's funny about that? It's
actually the anti-vax people that are being paid
when the science is clear. You don't need to
pay anyone to report on the science. And this
is a very good point that was made to me in the
email, which is David. You know, when people write
to you and they say, or they leave a voicemail
saying you're getting paid to promote the vaccine.
First of all, there's no evidence anybody is being
paid to promote the vaccine. But you don't really
need to pay people to just look at science
and report it, whereas we know of prominent
anti-vaxxers actually being paid influencers.
Speaker 5: Really, how how much are you must
be raking in the Bucks man to
be going attacking ivermectin?
A human drug that's used worldwide for years,
and it's on the World Health Organization list
of essential drugs for humans.
Speaker 1: Well, as we talked about before,
it used for roundworm parasites. So this this is
this is just a peek into the voicemail. We've got
a great bonus show for you today. In the midst of
all this, Texas Republican Governor Greg Abbott
is banning all vaccine mandates. France will ban
plastic packaging for most fruits and vegetables.
That seems logical, right? And we'll talk
about Samsung's continued struggles with their
foldable mobile phones. What's going on there?
Trouble in tech paradise. All of those stories
and more on today's business show. Sign up at
Join Pack NME.com and you will get instant access.